[Musique]
plusieurs mois c'est ce que prennent la
plupart des voyageurs pour se préparer
avant un départ je reviens ici en france
où j'ai grandi après deux ans et demi au
canada et j'ai emmené ma fille avec moi
alors évidemment c'est préparer avant le
voyage la liste des activités qu'on
allait à faire la conduite à tenir dans
les transports dans l'est dans les
aéroports la liste de ce qu'on allait
pouvoir rpt manger à la boulangerie et
puis moi aussi évidemment en tant
qu'adulte je me suis préparé les bagages
les réservations les bons plans les
papiers d'identité etc on se prépare
tous avant un voyage
et pourtant alors qu'on s'apprête à
emménager dans la plus grande métropole
du monde
avec plusieurs milliards d'habitants
des quartiers entiers dédiés à notre vie
personnelle ou professionnelle
où on passera 27 ans notre vie
activement internet on ne se prépare pas
alors chaque semaine parfois chaque jour
je vais faire un tour dans le plus grand
quartier professionnels du monde avec
plus de 800 millions d'habitants
d'utilisateurs je vais sur linked in
alors au mont terme ça permet de
maintenir développer son réseau pour une
semaine et puis au quotidien ça permet
de voir comment les carrières et les
projets des autres évoluent donc chaque
jour amène son lot de postes divers et
variés donc si par exemple j'ai un
contact qui vient de faire un poste
parce qu'il a créé son entreprise donc
je vais aller le voir je vais aller le
féliciter et l'encourager repartage
éventuellement pour donner de la
visibilité
si j'ai un autre contact une ancienne
collègue qui vient d'animer un atelier
avec lequel elle a eu beaucoup de succès
et qu'elle crée un poste à ce sujet je
vais légalement la féliciter je vais
même célébré avec les petites mains
vertes
si j'ai un autre contact carrément a
décroché un nouveau job ou une promotion
alors là le coeur bravo tu mérites et
c'est donc super tous les jours ça bouge
super fort qu'on va contacter donc c'est
vraiment génial
après c'est vrai que parfois moi de mon
côté j'ai l'impression que ma carrière a
explosé à tout ça elle évolue un petit
peu au ralenti du chaque quartier de la
ville connectée peu mal mais son lot de
complexe donc
je ne voyage pas assez sur facebook je
suis moche sur instagram est
incompétente sur l'île
mais je devrai masri me rassurer puisque
je ne suis pas la seule
en fait le cerveau procès parce qu'on
appelle des comparaisons social de
manière spontanée même sous le niveau de
conscience dès qu'on expose à des
informations sur les réseaux sociaux
il a été montré que plus on passe de
temps sur facebook et plus on a de
chances de faire des comparaisons
sociales négatives on se dévalorise et
plus on passe de temps de sur facebook
et plus on a de chance aussi de penser
que les autres sont plus heureux de nous
qu'ils ont meilleure vite nous et s'est
aussi associé à moins de satisfaction
dans la vie
les comparaisons sociales négatives sont
aussi associés à la dépression
alors pourquoi
et bien quand on est exposé à des postes
sur les réseaux sociaux on explosait cas
des fragments de vie qui sont
sélectionnés et éviter pour mettre en
valeur le profil
ce qu'on oublie aussi c'est que quand le
cerveau est exposé à ces postes il est
confronté à ce qu'on appelle le biais de
correspondance donc c'est un filtre du
cerveau qui va nous faire interpréter
beaucoup à partir de très très peu ce
biais cependant ce dont tu vas nous
faire oublier que les postes auxquels
nous sommes exposés ou les photos sont
l'objet de toute une mise en scène
de tout dérape et parfois aussi en faire
plusieurs
ils vont nous faire oublier aussi que va
une fois qu'on a à sélectionner la photo
il faut les éditer mettre des filtres la
découpe et comme il faut et puis
évidemment ce même biais de
correspondance nous fait croire que va
concrètement tous les postes qu'on ne
voit reflète l'avis de tous nos contacts
sauf qu'en fait les postes auxquels on
est exposés ne reflète que des fragments
de vie sélectionné et édité de ceux qui
postent uniquement
alors comment on fait avec ça
et bien en cyberpsychologie donc la
psychologie spécialisé dans les
comportements en ligne on prend
conscience de ce biais de correspondance
on essaye de contourner cet obstacle
effectivement il a été démontré que
si on maintient on arrive à maintenir
même en restant connectés des
conversations en direct sur des sujets
de vie fréquemment avec des contacts
s'est associé à moins d'un satisfaction
de la vie à moins de comparaison
sociales négatives
donc en cyberpsychologie on apprend un
petit peu comment les limites du cerveau
nous confronte à des obstacles dans un
environnement connecté et puis on essaye
d'adapter nos comportements
et bien cognitif ne sont autres que des
raccourcis économique pour le cerveau
qui jouent déjà leur rôle hors ligne
mais sur internet on a des facteurs
spécifiques comme le volume colossal
d'information leur renouvellement
accéléré
les dynamiques sociales de masse la
désinhibition aussi en ligne qui va
rendre ces biais amplifié et cumulé
il semblerait que shark est derrière
chaque aspect négatif de la vie
connectée peuvent se cacher des biais
donc par exemple sur les apps de dating
sur les sites de rencontres
la perspective de trouver le grand amour
peut nous confronter aux biais
d'optimisme
c'est un bien qui va nous faire négliger
l'information suspecte parce qu'on est
tellement motivé et que notre méfiance
ne se soulève pas
aujourd'hui le fbi ya même des
recommandations
pour lutter contre ce via d'optimisme
qui nous rendons vulnérables aux
arnaques amoureuse comme par exemple le
fait de s'alerter si un contact sur une
nappe de dating nous déclare sa flamme
trop vite trop tôt avant même qu'on ait
eu un appel vidéo
après tout l'agent secret déployés à des
milliers de kilomètres qui voulaient se
marier avec moi au bout de quelques
semaines et qui avait besoin de dix
mille euros pour une opération du coeur
qui lui sauverait la vie c'était
romantique mais j'aurais pu m'en doutais
dans une étude de 2018 il a été montré
aux états unis que deux porsche ou deux
pour cent des gens croient fermement que
la terre est plate
et 5 % des gens parmi eux les plus
jeunes adultes
qui avait toujours cru que la terre
était ronde avait de plus en plus de
doutes alors tant mieux pour la
développement de la société de la terre
plate de flat earth society
mais effectivement les fake news peuvent
prospérer à cause des biais mettre en
danger notre démocratie
donc on a par exemple le biais de
confirmation qui est un billet qui va
rendre très difficile le fait de
remettre en cause une thèse à laquelle
on a adhéré même avec l'émotion parce
que c'était
partagé par un influenceur qu'on aimait
bien et bien ce biais de confirmation va
nous faire négliger toutes les
informations même factuel et démontrer
qu'ils vont remettre en cause cette
thèse
on a aussi le biais d'illusions de
vérité qui va agir puisque avec les
algorithmes on a tendance à être
surexposée à des informations qui sont
donc quoi cohérente qui sont autour des
mêmes thèmes et c est ce bien division
de vérité va nous va nous faire va nous
rendre capables d'accepter comme vrai
une idée que l'on savait fausse
simplement si c'est suffisamment répété
exposés
aujourd'hui en france 20 % des
adolescents de 10 à 18 ans sont victimes
de cyber harcèlement
et combien d'entre eux savent
que la distance géographique d
environnement connecté crée aussi une
distance émotionnelle qui nous empêchent
de jouir de nos capacités d'empathie et
d'anticiper correctement la douleur que
l'on peut infliger autrui même avec un
énième commentaires négatifs sur un
poste
combien d'entre eux également savent que
être acceptée dans un groupe est un
besoin biologique exacerbée
effectivement à l'adolescence mais qui
nous confrontent donc au biais de
groupes c'est bien deux groupes vont
nous faire rendre acceptable des actes
bien plus violent que le nom elle aurait
accepté si on n'était pas avec l' envie
d'être accepté dans ce groupe
que se passera-t-il si on apprenait cela
même avant d'exister sur les réseaux
sociaux
eh bien on a un début de réponse puisque
en finlande il existe des programmes qui
commence dès la maternelle et qui prenne
en compte ces bières et qui autour
d'activités évidemment ludiques
permettent au final de régler 85% des
cas de harcèlement et de cyber
harcèlement scolaire
en cyber psychologie
on apprend donc les limites de notre
cerveau
pour les contourner en comprenant le
problème on peut trouver des solutions
sa part être du bon sens mais ce bon
sens malheureusement il ne trouve pas sa
réalité pratique
on parle de billets comme ça mais c'est
pas l'objet de réflexes au quotidien
puisque ce n'est pas l'objet d'
apprentissages fondamentaux
et pourtant dans un environnement où on
apprend à lire ne devrait-on pas
aujourd'hui tous hyper connecté à
apprendre à décrypter
j'étais passionné par les neurosciences
avant même de savoir comment ça
s'appelait j'ai étudié ici à bordeaux et
puis j'ai commencé ma carrière à
l'université d'oxford ont qu'un des buts
derrière plutôt glamour et quand j'ai
finalement décidé d'arrêter de couper
des têtes de rat pour regarder à
l'intérieur
j'ai intégré l'industrie digitale il ya
une dizaine d'années donc j'ai pu
contribuer à l'innovation dans les
séances digital avec des gros de la tête
donc super intéressant applicable
quotidien et puis en parallèle je suis
devenue maman
et si tout va bien il me reste
statistiquement à peu près 17 18 mois
avant que ma fille de 6 ans me le
demande un smartphone
alors le problème n'est pas le
smartphone le problème c'est pas les
apps
encore moins les écrans
après tout jeune interdirait pas ma
fille d'aller visiter une capitale
étrangère jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
il faudrait que je sois rassuré sur la
manière dont elle est capable de
maîtriser un minimum le code de la route
sur place les règles de base de sécurité
comment elle peut s'assurer voilà
d'éviter des contacts malveillants mais
aussi bien sûr de respecter les autres
pour avoir accès à des expériences très
riche social un accès à la culture des
expériences inédites avec des amis etc
et internet finalement
c'est la même chose
c'est simplement que ce code de la vie
de connecter on ne lui enseigne pas
ou alors pas du tout assez et
certainement pas ses taux
mais c'est en ayant passé ma vie à
m'intéresser au cerveau en en faisant
carrément mon métier dans le bus dans le
milieu du digital je n'essaie pas de
démocratiser ses connaissances à qui je
pourrais reprocher de n'avoir rien fait
alors internet a prouvé son lien avec
une meilleure qualité de vie qu'elle
soit personnelle professionnelle et
sociale
mais si on ne fait pas attention aux
limites que l'on a et à ses faiblesses
qui nous rend différents sur internet ou
en tout cas qui nous font part être
différent je crois que l'on met à
l'épreuve ce que l'on a de plus cher à
notre humanité et c'est ce que j'appelle
les deux joyaux de notre cerveau notre
empathie et notre pensée critique
alors il est vrai qu'on s'est souvent
intéressés à la technologie en se
demandant des risques ce que ça pouvait
représenter
notamment se focalisant sur sa puissance
de calcul
mais si finalement c'est pas en se
familiarisant avec ce que l'on a de
moins ces limites du cerveau ces biais
cognitifs en ligne que l'on pouvait
rendre nos expériences connecter plus
humaine avec ce qu'il ya de meilleur
dans l'humain et non pas du pire
et si finalement démocratisant ses
connaissances en leur donnant leur place
on ne pouvait pas bénéficier de la plus
puissante et la plus pérenne les
protections contre les risques sur
internet
notre tête
alors je vous tends la main aujourd'hui
pour que ses connaissances du cerveau
connectés prennent une place aussi
importante que les gestes qui sauvent
parce que je crois qu'on
fondamentalement qui pourrait sauver
notre société aujourd'hui merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]